it's the section of the tech 82
listening insect is part 20 starting in
section 456 page 158 on your copies the
important thing the important thing to
understand here is is what kind of files
tech uses in order to get all the
information it needs about fonts and
these are called TFM files tech font
metric files and they are used not only
by tech but by other system programs and
the design was intended whoops to make
them to make it a compact way to to
communicate lots of information these
were designed by Lao Ramshaw who's
sitting here in the audience today and
so he's going to be bored by this by
this hour but he can also correct me in
case I make mistakes at so a TFM file
consists of a long string of 8-bit bites
when we send you a TFM file we found
that the easiest way to do it so that
nobody could get confused by this is by
sending these bytes in decimal with
spaces between them so that the bytes
would say zero space 255 space or
whatever in decimal everybody has been
able to read those kinds of files then
you can then there's us a two or three
line program in Fortran or something
which will convert those into whatever
your local conventions are for files
that are made out of 8-bit bytes packed
file of a few bites but this is but that
Rick seems to vary greatly between
systems as far as tech is concerned it
just calls it a bite file which means a
packed file of 8-bit
and eight bits is our numbers between 0
and 255 and it has to be 0 to 255 not
minus 128 to plus 127 when we when we
can when we refer to something from the
bite file we're going to get the next
byte from it and it's got to be a number
between 0 and 255 you have to do
something to make sure that that that
assumption is valid but that's the only
assumption we make about bike files now
actually you could also consider it as a
32-bit words because the number of bytes
in the file is always a multiple of 4
and we always read it and we always read
them almost always read them four bytes
at a time oh it's only at the beginning
when we read them two bites at a time
and so if it's if you wanted to you
could you could imagine it as consisting
of these words but all of the but for
tech purposes it was more it was it was
better to stick to smaller number of
file types if possible so we so Tech has
alpha files byte files in the word files
needed those three anyway didn't want to
go to a fourth one which was made out of
32-bit words from TFM file let's think
of it as bites but four bytes to a word
so I'm going to draw my lines here
indicating of 4 bytes it four bytes and
I'm going to consider that the the bites
are left to right located in a word so
zero by zero the file bite 1 x 2 x 3 and
so on this is what Lyle calls big endian
order where the big end is that right
you nodded your head this way it's
called the ending in order but I didn't
invent the term Dan Cohen of bias I and
to the term in a very amusing essay
about by order inside of words okay
because they go in different in
different ways and and that's why we
transmit them as bites
this way but I'm going to represent them
in on the board assuming that this is
your first bite second bite third by
fourth way that's just a convention for
the way I the way I right right and now
that the the first part of the file is
six words long so it's always fixed and
it tells you how big the rest of the
file is and it has 12 half words in it
12 16-bit integers that are composed of
the first bite x 256 plus the second
bite that's the big endian order there
so this is the the length and we've got
a whole bunch of these things they're
all described in module 4 57 I'll just
read them to you God to so you get the
feeling of it that first comes the
length of the entire file in words so
the length of the header data so that
rest is the neck the next parts of the
file there's the header and then there's
the char info done let me try to do it
from memory and then I can correct it
afterward this would be more fun for me
I don't be confusing for you if I get it
wrong but let's hope I get it right then
comes the width then comes the heights
our and comes the depth in comes the
italic Corrections then comes the
ligature current instructions then comes
I plan ahead here got to get me then
come the currents and then come the
extensible characters and finally the
parameters that's all just made it how
did I get it right Wow okay turns yeah
now so start out length of the file then
the length of the header park then it's
been the next two half words here are
the beginning character and ending
character the font and characters don't
have to be consecutive inside there's
another way to indicate gaps inside but
but this is it are more efficient if we
can if you don't have two characters in
the font one of which is number zero and
the other is which 255 because then we
have more space in your the the char
info gives can give it starts at BC and
ends at ec and so if you so there will
be zeros in here for four missing
characters but the fewer those are the
fewer words of char info you need
charring pho is packed as I'll describe
later giving for each character in the
font of information about its actual
width height depth Nutella those piece
of information are indirect pointers to
the width height depth and italic
errection parts of the form
file that come next so char info Wow is
here then you specify the number of
widths a number of heights the number of
depths the number of italic Corrections
the length of your league a number of
commands you have of ligatures currents
the number of currents the number of
extension parts the number of parameters
so the this first part just gives the
length of all those and there's a
formula has to be satisfied that the
length of the file has to be 6 plus
length of the header plus you know and
so on that that has to be checked and so
you'll know something's wrong if that
equation doesn't doesn't work out
correctly now the beginning character
and ending character are supposed to
satisfy the relation bc minus 1 less
than or equal i see less than or equal
to 55 inside of the tech 82 I'm not
saying that bc has to be less than or
equal DC you could have beginning
character equals 1 and eat any character
equals 0 that's the empty font it's not
a particularly interesting font but the
I just put it I just made sure that it
would be legal because history of
mathematics indicated that it was useful
to have 0 around and so sometimes a
person might want to be able to input an
old fine but that does a b c minus one
really have to be gradual equals zero i
believe so what happens a pc a zero no
you're right bc just has to be greater
than or equals zero sorry yeah excuse me
and that's all I said to in that section
now the definition of biometric data not
only is in this section but it's also in
the other hand not that you have called
tech where and the program in there
called tf2 PL is the is the i believe
it's got starts at page 200
in one it's the second program in the in
the book they it jumps from page 110 to
page 201 tf2 PL contains a separate
description of you know just copied out
a tech of this of these fonts again
it'sit's reproduced there but with a
slight more generality because this
isn't intended for also for processors
that are a little more general in test
and so there will be a comment in in
that section that's not in the tech
manual if you look at module eight of
tf2 PL it'll say exception to these
rules is planned for oriental fonts
which will be identified by the
condition e C equals 256 we're planning
to say that if EC is 256 then we're
going to do something special in an
extension attack well say something
about that that plan the saving thing
about oriental characters like Japanese
or Chinese is that they don't have that
many different widths heights and depths
their effect they're almost always the
same the they have lots and lots of
different different shapes of characters
but only a few websites and depth so
inside of tech we would represent those
as a character code first of all it
tells what its width height and depth is
and then we would have another bit
another thing after it 16 bits that
tells exactly what glyph it is in the
font and by looking looking for a font
that has something that has EC equal to
56 we tech in such an extension would
know to look for a glyph code besides to
figure out what character what the
actual character is but the first part
of it would be treated just as usual by
tech to figure out this the width height
and depth so the character the different
widths heights and depths would be
described in the New ordinary way okay
well
that's something that we would then they
then I think we were going to say
character 256 would maybe refer to would
represent all of the other ones or
something like that that there's no
large proposal worked out I just wanted
to make sure that this kind of thing
would would be easy to graft in without
much difficulty okay now inside of these
char info parts we have that we have the
highly compressed data which makes it
possible to do this most most of the
time the rest of this is these tables
are also going to be fairly short in
fact well we can find out how how big
these files are I suppose let me let me
just type something here so I can you
let me see I'm not going to be doing
anything real interesting so you don't
have to see it yourself but on but if
you want if you want to we could switch
over to the computer now for just to
test it all you link and you can you dim
the house lights now and go to the
computer terminal and see you can see if
we can get anything here i'm going to
try see mr chen TFM on texas and type it
out in octal is to see what see how long
it is
that's it can anybody see and now this
is the beginning of the file you see
those are those that header information
appearing in the first six word can you
see it no yeah they'd like to see the
computer screen is that connected okay
see what a dreadful thing you have to
watch me all the time I I can't stand to
look at mirrors now they do so this is
the beginning you see the the length of
the file in words is 250 knocked oh no
no wait a min we got to be careful
because either 36-bit words and their
shifted left so what what is that really
00 215 now let's see that's 3 6 9 12 15
bits so we need 16 bits so that will
really be 10 L really before 40 when 32
octo which is a 44 x 64 256 24 more 26
more 256 and 26 282 something like that
282 words so typically we're running
between 250 and 300 words for the top
for the for the whole log TFM file you
see the next part of the file coming
through there this would be your char
info words for the for this roman font
after the header the header the header
contains the name in of the final say
computer modern or something like that
and technically pretty much ignores that
but then the character info parts most
of these are 0 that's when the the
height and depth of the depth is 0 for
example on most of these characters and
the bulk of the information is taken by
the char info table and at the end we're
going to get things where there are more
bits on probably
and that's when we're getting into the
hype the actual width data and height
data but looks like most binary dump
files okay so back to the house lights
on again then it's packed highly
condensed and so we have the tf2 PL
program available to print that in
symbolic form and we'll we'll take a
look at what it prints from that binary
data in a minute well the charring
forwards are packed into they have four
bytes to them the first bite second bite
third bite and forth buyer gets a zero
the person saying this one is width and
it's a pointer into the width table if
the width is zero however this means the
character is not there just the
condition width equals zero is the is in
is necessary and sufficient for our tech
is concern saying don't put it in the
DVI clock and and give an error message
if the user wants to be told about such
errors so it's an 8-bit pointer we could
handle almost all cases however if
somebody has 256 nonzero widths in his
and 256 characters in the font then we
couldn't have we couldn't handle them
all because we only have two we have but
we have 20 is reserved for a flag to
indicate not present the next one height
and depth is packed four bits for height
and Corbett's for depth which means that
we're only allowing 16 different heights
16 different depths furthermore the
first width is zero the first height is
zero the first steps is 0 first to tell
it correction is 0 this is a convention
also that we can help to check that
we've got a TFM file and well that
doesn't really hurt you because you
usually want
of at least one character that has
height zero or depth zero so you're not
paying but now so you can so if you have
a font that has more than 16 different
heights in it the program will round to
the code to the closest the closest ones
that it had it'll take all the heights
that are there and it'll pick 16 of them
so that the maximum error is as small as
possible that's of note that's of little
consolation however if your height is
represents the thickness of a rule of a
square root sign so so we're careful to
design our symbol spawn so that whenever
we have a square root sign it's it's not
going to be in a front that's that's
Heights are getting rounded they're
going to be exact heights given but
typically this isn't this is plenty and
we only have them any bits so that's it
so four bits for height four bits for
depths are packed in there metallic
correction and tag are here but this is
six bit bit so this is 8-bit slide 44
this is six and two italic correction
and we have sixty six bits so we can
have 64 different nutella corrections in
the file and in my if I'm not well if
I'd if I calculate each italic
correction in by a tricky math formula
then I tend to get 65 or 66 of them in a
typical italic font of 128 characters
but that but rounding doesn't really
bother me on metella corrections that I
won't see the difference of a percentage
point of a point so we got that thing
then the tag field which it which has
four values and then there's the
remainder field which is a which is sort
of like a parameter to the tag eight
bits now the tag has four values and
0 1 2 & 3 0 is the vanilla case the
normal case and almost all characters
have a tag of 0 tag of one is League it
says the ligature current program is
there and in that case the remainder is
a pointer into the ligature current
commands and we start looking there to
see what about ligatures and currents
will talk a little bit more about that
in a minute type 2 is where we have a
character list and this means we there
is a next larger character in some list
of characters for example left
parenthesis might be might be linked
together and and and so we can get the
knit to the next larger one bye-bye and
the remainder is a pointer to the to the
character that's next larger in the
sequence and that can point to still
another one and so on so we can find
week we have a we can have lists of
characters and the last one is extent
the third cases for an extensible
character in that case the remainder
field is a pointer into the extensible
into the extensible recipes for making
up extensible characters well I can
explain extensible recipes right now
extensible recipes have four parts top
middle bottom and repeatable part and
these are the names of four characters
in the font or they might be 0 in this
in these three case they might be 0
indicating that the thing isn't present
so we make up repeatable characters in
that way for example the left brace of
curly brace has 4 has off all four
things present repeatable part is this
here gets repeated as many times as you
need the same number of times above and
below the middle part of course is this
the top part this about and part that
for different characters
and tech will will take top any number
you know n of these then middle then
again of these and end the bottom if
middle is empty that would it be
indicated by zero here that would be a
character like a left parenthesis as
just the top of bottom and a repeater
part font designer should drop should to
make a good font the font designer
should make the this set of all
different widths that you can get be the
same for all of his de limiters for you
shouldn't for example so that if you'd
have a left parenthesis with the
repeater part of six points then your
your repeater part for braces should be
three points each so so that you'll have
the same sequence of length because when
tech is is the matching suppose somebody
for some reason one of the left
parenthesis in a right brace it would be
funny if the right brace would be a
different size from the left parenthesis
just because the set of different
available heights is it's different for
the two you'd like to make them
consistent so so you design it so that
the set of different things that that
that that can be made up has the same
has the same dimensions anyway you take
a symbol like vertical line that doesn't
have top middle or bottom so our
repeater parts and one of these floor
brackets has bottom but no top and so on
I haven't seen one yet that has a middle
and nothing up but could you can imagine
all those combinations the repeater part
is always there even if it's zero it's
that new that would mean that zero is
your repeater character but but if it's
an extensible character this is used in
certain parts of tech math mode to see
if you have if if this character is an
extensible character and then then it
would see if the tag is three what about
the ligature current programs I think
I've covered everything about this
except parameters and ligature current
commands because wit sidesteps these are
just the different
debs I gotta mention though that these
are given in in certain units because
they represent physical dimensions so we
ought to talk about those units the only
header in the header part there's two
important words far as tech is concerned
and I forget which comes first in which
comes second but the fee offers is the
checksum and next is the young is the
design sighs so we got to talk about
those two things checksum first that's a
number that's supposed to be that's
supposed to change if if if text in
important information is different if
for example somebody is if uses tech to
produce a DVI file in January and then
you use that DVI file to print in
February the checksum that tech found in
its in its TFM file that use in January
should agree with the checksum that's
being used in February to print the font
otherwise there's been an
incompatibility okay and so this text um
is computed by marathon if the checksum
is zero it doesn't get the know test is
made but but but otherwise user is
warned that something has happened to
the font in the meantime say so that the
assumptions that tech made generating
the file are not necessarily valid
anymore and we can't mine may be printed
correctly so beware that's what the
checksum is for the design site is is
this so besides that the that's sort of
normal for this font with that the
designer had in mind it's a but it's
kind of an arbitrary thing it's just
what all the other units are expressed
in terms of so all the widths are
expressed as multiples of the design
sighs all the heights depths atella
corrections currents
and parameters except one parameter is
pure number but all the other parameters
are expressed as multiples of the design
side and the design size doesn't
necessarily have to have to reflect any
universal truth or something but if you
say that you but that your design size
is ten points this is given in units of
points then then if somebody just calls
for this font without saying at a
certain other size then he gets it at
ten points design size is sort of the
default aunt's eyes so a person in in
writing in tech will say font 10 equals
CMR 10 and its design size happens to be
10 and the design size of CM r9 happens
to be 9 but if he says CMR 10 at 15
point then tech just reads in the same
TFM file but pretends that 15 was the
design size here and so everything is in
a multiple of the design size so
everything gets multiplied by x 15
instead now these wit these widths are
actually given as as what the
documentation calls fixed words and
fixed words are
are our fixed point things that have 20
bits to the right of the decimal point
so there's 20 bits to the right of the
decimal point and therefore 12 to the
left of the decimal point okay now that
the fixed words however it should not
actually use all this precision to the
left of decimal point Tech is only going
to allow them to use 8 bits to left
decimal point or is it for four bits
yeah only for those should actually be
used so we're not saying so nobody's
supposed to have a width more than 16
times the design sighs sorry so for
example if you really want to you know
to have something more than 16 mm so the
design sighs we might call an M is
typically as it is one-quarter 1m if
somebody really wants to have a
character that's more than 16 ms in some
direction or other he should say that
his design size is larger okay and the
reason is that then tech can can do the
conversion multiplying by the design
size with a single precision without a
lot of time and saves it saves it saves
these internal calculations so the so
these are given its fixed word so the
first bite will either be 0 or 2 55 but
it an egg ative is given in two's
complement notation so the first bite
has to be 0 or 2 55 in all the website
steps parameters okay now to leak later
current commands here's where we got
another another highly efficient way to
pack logic into bits and ligature
current command table is a big the big
table of instructions possibly big but
but possibly he's empty and if the tag
bit was one that would say the remainder
is an index into this table as to where
we start
there's four bit 4 byte commands in the
table and and you can you do and you
execute this command and if it didn't
find something then you go on to the
next one now the commands have four
parts and the first one is called the
stop bite or the stock bit this one is
called the OP I think this one is called
no this one is called the character and
this one is called the op and this one
is called the remainder or the upper end
or something I don't have a specific
name for call it remainder and the
command has a following the the right
now we're using one bit for stop one bit
for up eight bits per character and
eight bits for remainder so people like
Pierre Makai have been eyeing these
extra 14 bits with great interest
because they want to do things for
arabic and other languages that where
they would like to go beyond 256
character limit right now we're just
using the high-order bit in the stop
bite and the out bite the commands means
this look at the next character
following the present one and that it
doesn't match this one if not go on to
the next instruction or stop depending
on whether the stop it is there so the
first thing is look for a match on the
character after it and if and if you
didn't find it then you stop if this
stop it is on otherwise you go on and
sequentially until you either find a
match or you find a stop it now if you
did find a match then the OP it tells
you it's either a leader or a current if
it's a if it's a Kern then you'd look at
the remainder part and that's an index
into this current table here tell you
how much the current is if it's a
ligature the remainder tells you replace
your present character and the following
character by this one and then start the
whole process over again
pretend that that was the character that
was input and go through and see if that
character in turn has a ligature tag and
if so it will refer to it to its program
to continue on so see what happens then
f for example in a typical American
version of ligatures f has a ligature
program that says are you follow if
you're followed by an F then replace
this by FF character as a ligature and
go on if you're followed by and I
replace it by Fi and and and and same
for L somewhere then FF itself FF
ligature is followed by an eye then
replace that by f fi f would also be
followed for two also often followed by
currents for example F followed by a !
you'd want to put some extra space
between f and information point so that
they don't run into each other quote
marks same way okay so that's the idea
of these ligature turn instructions and
command and tech will interpret this in
several parts of the of the program so
let's now see what the tf2 PL program
does with this and so let's have the
lights off and go back to the computer
and see if this works is still up tf2 PL
tf2 PL is a program that is is one of
these tech where programs that you've
got and it asked me for this pfm file
and i'll just use the cmr 10 TFM that on
texas that we were just looking at in
binary on this end called printout cmr
10 dot PL and this is the this is the
program that you have a listing of doing
it prints out the character codes that
it has a process as it's doing it okay
so now we should be able to look at cmr
to